we saw the special counsel yesterday
makes that statement he analyzed eleven
instances where there were possible
obstruction and then said that he really
couldn't make a decision do you agree
with that interpretation I personally
felt he could have reached the decision
in your view he could have reached her
conclusion right he could have reached a
conclusion the opinion says you cannot
indict a president while he's in office
but he could have reached a decision as
to whether it was criminal activity but
he had his reasons for not doing it
which he explained and I'm not going to
you know argue about those reasons but
when he didn't make a decision the
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosen Stein
and I felt it was necessary for us as
the head of the department to reach that
decision well I mean he seemed to
suggest yesterday that there was another
venue for this and that was Congress
well I'm not sure what he was suggesting
but you know the Department of Justice
doesn't use our powers of investigating
crimes as an adjunct to Congress